good evening thanks for joining us here
at 11 i'm denise valdez
well now that the vaccine is rolling out
across the world many of us are eager to
think about traveling again maybe just
seeing a movie or show on the strip
but some say to better protect everyone
we should carry proof
that we've been vaccinated in the form
of a vaccine passport
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
spoke with an infectious disease
expert and travelers to get their take
madison
yes the technology is already out there
but many airlines and tech companies are
now working together to create mobile
medical records for travel
while thousands line up for the vaccine
could that protection from the virus
translate to a vaccination certificate
allowing you a fast track to travel
[Applause]
or a clean bill of health to attend a
crowded venue some experts predict we
could be on the path to a vaccine
passport
a digital credential that proves your
virus free i agree with it
and not only the united states i would
think that this would be something that
they should have throughout the whole
world
there are already apps and systems to
upload details of a covet 19
test and medical records but a
certificate to prove your
health may go too far for some i think
that's kind of outrageous
really to be showing that everywhere you
go but others agree with the idea
people want to go out of town and go to
other countries and you're taking it
over there or bringing it back
so no no definitely a good idea to get
that vaccine patty ollinger the
executive director of the global biorisk
advisory council
shares that while americans have the
choice to get the vaccine
it may change the activities we're able
to do i always have that choice of
here in the united states at least that
i'm not going to get the vaccine
but then i may not have entry into
certain areas
or i may not you know have that job that
i
want if it's a requirement for
employment
and the common trust networks are the
ones to come up with the common pass app
and so far they have partnered with
several international airlines reporting
live madison kimbrough
8 news now so with that in mind would
you be on board with having to show
proof of vaccinations in order to travel
let's say outside of our country
we posted that poll to our twitter and
hundreds of you
chimed in and more than half of you said
yes you would be willing to carry that
vaccination certificate